baby sitting jean-philippe ou encore la
haine
ces films ont en commun de leurs lieux
de tournage les yvelines nombreux sont
les réalisatrices et réalisateur à avoir
posé leur caméra dans notre département
parmi les villes les plus prisées
versailles
tout cela est ridicule tout cela madame
c'est vers ça en 2005 la réalisatrice
américaine sofia coppola choisi la ville
du roi soleil pour son film marie
antoinette
la plupart des scènes sont tournées au
petit trianon au hameau de la reine et
bien sûr au château dont la
privatisation coûte 300 mille euros
autres lieux plus insolites à être
régulièrement prisé par les équipes de
tournage l'hôtel du département pour sa
ressemblance notamment avec l'elysée
juillet 2017
olivier baroux investi les lieux pendant
quelques jours pour les tuche 3 bassorah
occupe ce président à temps quand moi je
vous dis j'ai voté pour vous jef devient
président de la république donc bien
évidemment cette salle servait à réunir
les ministres et dans la salle du
conseil des ministres était juste à côté
il en avait fait la chambre à coucher
des peluches
c'est en 1989 que l'hôtel du département
a cueilli son premier tournage avec
l'opération corned beef de jean marie
poiré ou encore le film l'assaut avec
vincent elbaz en 2010
à cette époque les lieux été cédé à
titre gracieux ce n'est que depuis 2018
que le département a mis en place une
convention payante
en gros une journée de tournage ça
comprend donc trois jours
d'immobilisation parce que vous avez une
journée de montage une journée de
tournage et puis de trois heures de
démontage
il faut compter trois mille six cents
euros la gare de ben est également
choisi pour le film les tuche 3 elle
représente la gare de bouzols d'où le
tgv part à quelques kilomètres de là
l'église san martin de thoiry sert de
décor pour le film les visiteurs sorti
en 1993
le département des yvelines déjà un très
beau département donc qui associe le
monde économique le monde
comment dire agricole donc c'est vrai
que c'est des paysages très variés avec
beaucoup de lieux historiques
je pense que c'est des centaines de
films qui ont été réalisés en partie
dans les yvelines
si la majeure partie des films tournés
sont français quelques scènes du dernier
opus dans girl games ont été réalisés en
2015 dans les yvelines et direction le
château de voisins a senti larion près
de rambouillet ce domaine privé et la
demeure du président snow la roseraie
ainsi que les intérieurs sont visibles
dans le film désolé m dames je crois pas
vous laisser passer les fellahs entrée
j'en prends la responsabilité proximité
avec paris et richesse de ses paysages
et de son patrimoine autant d'arguments
qui font des yvelines une terre très
prisée pour les tournages de films